[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit anna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend hinein an einem tag an dem
der blick gen himmel geht mit der bangen
frage was kommt da auf uns zu der
deutsche wetterdienst hatte für viele
teile deutschlands vor extremem unwetter
gewarnt vor orkanböen vor heftigem
starkregen
es hat so viel lässt sich jetzt bereits
sagen besonders hart die menschen im
raum paderborn lippstadt getroffen die
aktuellen bilder und entwicklungen dort
von oliver reichert
ein einkaufszentrum in paderborn eine
einzelne gewitterzellen entlädt ihre
zerstörerische gewalt richtet am
nachmittag große schäden dutzende
menschen sollen verletzt worden sein 30
bis 40 personen davon zehn schweren
sagte ein sprecher der kreispolizei am
freitagabend der nachrichtenagentur ap
demnach sei eine windhose wer durch die
stadt in nordrhein westfalen gezogen von
ost nach west und habe millionen teure
zerstörungen verursacht
die polizei spricht von einer schneise
der verwüstung sie berichtet von
abgedeckten dächern und den purzelten
bäumen sie seien auf autos gestürzt
berichtet ein dpa reporter
hier ist gerade chaos sagt eine
polizeisprecherin
auch im 35 kilometer entfernten
lippstadt hat am nachmittag ein tornado
massive zerstörungen verursacht
der ganze rat uns natürlich nach vorne
wickelräume ekstatisch abgebrochen hier
sind alle häuser im arsch
starkregen und orkanböen sorgen auch
hier für schwere sachschäden sind
verletzten oder gar toten ist derzeit
nichts bekannt
in einem freizeitbad wurden rund 120
badegäste eingeschlossen bei 1
umgestürzte bäume den eingang blockierte
später seien die eingeschlossenen
befreit worden berichtet die feuerwehr
möglichst zu hause bleiben rät die
polizei im moment vor ort spricht von
einer schneise der verwüstung wir sind
jetzt verbunden mit thomas wienecke er
ist kreisbrandmeister im lagezentrum in
soest eher wenige guten abend
beschreiben sie doch mal bitte die
aktuelle situation und auch die
herausforderung an sie jetzt als
feuerwehr
ja wir haben es tatsächlich erlebt dass
eine schneise der verwüstung entstanden
ist durch den tornado tornados durch das
ganze stadtgebiet link stadt gezogen und
anschließend auch durch die innenstadt
von paderborn das ist der nachbar kreis
paderborn und hat daher erhebliche
verwüstungen angerichtet
jetzt ist die rede in den ersten
meldungen von 30 bis 40 verletzten zehn
davon schwer können sie genaueres dazu
sagen
die anzahl der verletzten tatsächlich
ist im nachbarkreis
die genauen die genaue situation jetzt
kann ich da keine aussage dazu treffen
im kreise soest ist besucher wir sind
sprich in der stadt lippstadt dass wir
relativ glimpflich davon gekommen sind
es waren viele personen eingeschlossen
unter anderem ein cabriolet das ist ein
großes schwimmbad 120 personen
eingeschlossen sie konnten von der
feuerwehr befreit werden
da ist niemand verletzt worden von einer
kleineren nationen sind nur davon
getragen worden ansonsten sind wir gut
davon gekommen der kreis von dem orden
hingegen hat circa 40 verletzt aber dann
kann ich keine genaue auskunft darüber
geben thomas weniger ist
kreisbrandmeister im lagezentrum in
soest eher weniger vielen dank
und dann gucken wir auf die gesamtlage
für deutschland mit unserem zdf
meteorologen resident alien guten abend
er muss ich denn in deutschland jetzt
aktuell besonders in acht nehmen ja
aktuell sind im süden noch gewitter
unterwegs und da gälten auch
unwetterwarnungen teilweise vor
starkregen und sturmböen aber das
gröbste ist allmählich vorbei wir können
mal auf den satelliten film schauen
sehen wir diese roten spots quasi das
waren die gewitter heute und teilweise
die super zellen die
ja extremen regen gebracht haben sturm
und orkanböen und da ist auch die zelle
dabei die quasi den tornado in im westen
deutschlands da erzeugt hat ja und da
muss man sagen dass es schon ziemlich
heftig heute was da passiert ist die
zutaten waren gegeben wir haben auch
gewarnt wortlos und vielleicht gibt es
auch noch weitere die noch nicht
entdeckt worden herzlichen dank erstmal
für den moment ist sind ja live hier im
studio es ist nicht nur deutschland rund
um diesen planeten kämpfen die menschen
im moment mit rekorden die niemand gut
finden kann in frankreich eine
historische hitzewelle bis zu 35 grad im
mai flüsse und seen trocknen aus die
felder staubtrocken und es gibt große
sorge in frankreich um die ernte
in spanien ist der mai so heiß wie der
sommer luftmassen aus nordafrika lassen
das thermometer an manchen orten auf
mehr als 40 grad steigen
und das ist bagdad irak wo schwere
sandstürme durch die straßen fegen
tausende menschen müssen in den
krankenhäusern beatmet werden das land
kämpft gegen vermehrte trockenheit im
letzten jahr gab es eine der schlimmsten
dürren seit jahrzehnten
und überall die frage wie viel davon ist
wetter und was ist klima weltweit
gesehen waren die vergangenen sieben
jahre bereits die wärmsten seit beginn
der aufzeichnungen andreas linke
berichtet
es ist heiß in stuttgart und anderswo
sommer im mai die menschen auf den
plätzen genießen mit einiger skepsis
ich bin ja schon etwas älter und werden
früher auch hochsommer aber ich glaube
so früh und vor allem so trocken wie ist
dieses jahr oder letzten jahre habe ich
selten erlebt als ich habe jetzt das
gefühl dass es nicht im richtigen
übergang gab es ist sehr sehr schnell
heiß geworden und man merkt einfach
diese ganzen umstände verändern sich
einfach und damit werden die kinder
natürlich auch zu kämpfen haben noch mal
viel viel intensiver die wir alle hier
die zeichen der veränderung verdichten
sich wir haben bisher einen besonderen
mai doch für meteorologen hängt
ungewöhnliches wetter nicht zwingend mit
dem klimawandel zusammen
bisher haben wir noch in keiner station
in deutschland ein rekord hitzerekord
dieses jahr
erreicht das heißt es war alles schon
mal da
ungewöhnlich ist jetzt nur dass wir über
den langen zeitraum
bisher
so weit über dem langjährigen mittel
liegen derzeit bei etwa 25 grad
höhere temperaturen bedeuten mehr
energie in der atmosphäre und mehr
feuchtigkeit
dieses gemüse entlud sich etwa gestern
abend im kreis ludwigsburg bei stuttgart
als andere probleme im norden und vor
allem im osten deutschlands seit 2008
zehn herrscht hier eine dürre wie in den
vergangenen 250 jahren nicht im
altmarkkreis salzwedel wird aktuell das
bewässern verboten in den 70er jahren
gab es mal trockenheit in deutschland
als es vor allem am niederschlag
mangelte nun wird es auch noch werner
2018/2019 waren ausgeprägte hitze jahre
bei gleichzeitig unterdurchschnittlichen
niederschlagen das hat dazu geführt dass
ihm damals vor allem in der nordhälfte
deutschlands sich dürre bis in größere
tiefen des bodens ausgeprägt hat und
letztlich bis heute eben in teilen
diesen trockenen es noch nicht aufgelöst
werden konnte
immer mehr extrem wetter als ursache
beobachten forscher dass die dynamik der
wettersysteme abnimmt tiefs mit regen
und hofs mit trockenheit ziehen also
viel langsamer als früher bleiben länger
an einem ort
trocken tage wird die länger andauern
der beginn einer dürre sein könnte
genauso niederschlägen
erhoffte niederschläge die wenn wir der
hand dauern dann zu überschwemmungen
führen können und die ursache dafür
unter andere ist dass ich auch die die
dynamik in der atmosphäre durch den
klimawandel verändert
ungewöhnlich also aber erklärbar der
aktuell heiße start in den mai
und jetzt in der sendung nächste große
herausforderung der krieg und seine
folgen gerade menschen die sehr auf
jeden cent achten müssen trifft eine
toxische kombination aus inflation und
energiepreis wahnsinn mit voller wucht
der bundesrat hat heute das sogenannte
entlastungspaket endgültig auf den weg
gebracht die einen sagen es zeigt wir
lassen die menschen nicht allein die
anderen sagen das ist politik mit der
gießkanne
schauen wir uns die einzelnen teile mal
an da sind die spritpreise bei denen die
steuer gesenkt wird von juni bis august
bei benzin um 35 cent und bei diesel um
17 dann eine energiepreis pauschale von
300 euro die erwerbstätige im herbst
ausgezahlt bekommen sollen zudem sind
eine erhöhung der pendlerpauschale und
des sogenannten
grundfreibetrags dabei und familien mit
kindern wird geholfen etwa mit einem
einmaligen kindergeld bonus in aller
munde schon seit wochen dass neun euro
ticket eine echte premiere das
einsteigen in den nahverkehr soll für
eine begrenzte zeit so einfach und
günstig sein wie nie zuvor die details
hat sven rieken
hinter der fontäne auf der hamburger
binnenalster fahren fern regional und s
bahn züge über die gleichen gleise der
lombardsbrücke ein nadelöhr dass die
taktung der züge fest im griff hat nur
eines von vielen projekten in
deutschland die zusätzlich zu den
steigenden energiekosten zwischen bund
und ländern für gerangel sorgen wir
brauchen einfach ein gutes verlässliches
sicheres angeboten mit hoher qualität
guter taktung und guter vernetzung der
unterschiedlichen öffnen verkehrsmitteln
und das schafft man halt nicht mit
weniger geld ein einheitliches
tarifsystem würde auch helfen unter dem
dach des hamburger verkehrsverbundes
etwa sind fast 30 unternehmen versammelt
das angebot reicht von der nordsee bis
hinter liebig seit heute gibt es das
neun euro ticket online am schalter und
der app dort zu kaufen
der verbund sieht die subventionierte
monatskarte als längst überfällig an es
gab die abwrackprämie es gab die e auto
förderung die luft immer noch es gibt
das dienstwagenprivileg es gibt immer
wieder förderung für den autoverkehr für
die autonutzung und jetzt haben endlich
mal eine starke symbolträchtige
förderung explizit für den öpnv
subventionen die auch aus dem hause von
volker wissing kommen der
verkehrsminister kaufte sich heute
ebenfalls 1 9 euro ticket für seine
privaten fahrten die bilder in einem
berliner u-bahnhof zeigen was die aktion
ist eine 2 5 milliarden euro teure
marketing-kampagne und ein feldversuch
es ist nicht so dass wir jetzt einfach
nur einen neuen euro ticket machen und
im hintergrund nicht an verbesserungen
gearbeitet wird aber die erkenntnisse
die wir hier gewinnen werden die werden
natürlich auch ganz wertvoll sein weil
wir dann wissen was erwarten die
menschen ganz konkret von uns sicher
nicht solche bilder hier in der
uckermark etwa fährt der bus zweimal am
tag da hat einen neuen euro ticket wenig
überzeugungskraft ein solcher autonome
bus aber könnte helfen der elektrische
mini holt die fahrgäste auf anforderung
ab und bringt sie zum nächsten bahnhof
in hamburg sind die feldversuche in der
hafencity abgeschlossen das projekt
startet im kommenden jahr in zwei
außenbezirken wir müssen die erfahrung
sammeln wir müssen gerade auch schauen
wie schaffen wir das in nicht so dicht
besiedelten gebieten in hamburg im
speckgürtel die schaffen wir dann
angeboten dann muss man es auch
vorschauen wie kommt man weiter dabei
bei der mobilen wände dazu zu sagen aber
es hilft uns nicht auf dem platten land
bringt uns auch nicht weiter wir müssen
hier anfang an der bahntrasse zwischen
binnen und außenalster würde die stadt
auch gerne anfangen im gespräch ist ein
tunnel für die s-bahn das würde 2,6
milliarden euro kosten also nur wenig
mehr als die 25 milliarden für das 9
euro ticket so viel geld allerdings
sprudelt der zeit dann doch nicht für
den vip empfang
welche herausgehobene rolle der russland
lobbyist gerhard schröder beim ölkonzern
rosneft spielte wurde heute noch mal
klar rosneft lobt seinen bisherigen
aufsichtsrats-chef als einen mit
strategischer vision und einen von
unschätzbarem wert
strategische vision und unschätzbare
wert wohlgemerkt für russland und seine
führung schröder war auch mal
bundeskanzler das eu parlament fordert
jetzt dass gegen ihnen sanktionen
verhängt werden der bundestag hat ihm
das büro gestrichen und heute teilt der
altkanzler der bisher alle kritik
abprallen ließ dem russischen ölkonzern
mit es sei ihm zitat unmöglich seinen
posten weiter auszuüben anselm stern
er war einst der mächtigste mann in
deutschland kanzler gewählt auch von
vielen gefeiert für agenda und
friedenspolitik seit jahren nun schon
ist gerhard schröder unterwegs im
auftrag von russlands energie
staatskonzernen jetzt hört er auf bei
rosneft nach fast fünf jahren als chef
des aufsichtsrates fünf jahre in
bezahlten diensten russlands nicht der
einzige job schröder hat
führungsaufgaben bei der nord stream ag
und ist derzeit nominiert für den
aufsichtsrat bei gazprom wie lange noch
heute mehr als fraglich putins freund
war gerhard schröder schon während
seiner kanzlerzeit danach wurde er auch
zu putins mitarbeiter
2017 beim amtsantritt für rosneft klang
das so ich bin im gegenteil der
auffassung dass es vernünftig ist für
die friedliche entwicklung der welt ein
stabiles russland zu haben ökonomisch
wie politisch
und wenn man einen kleinen beitrag dazu
leisten kann dass das gelingt soll man
das tun das ist mein motiv zum motiv
heute warum jetzt der teilrückzug aus
dem lukrativen öl und gas lobbyismus
bislang kein öffentliches wort von
gerhard schröder der schritt kommt zwölf
wochen nach putins brutalen überfall auf
die ukraine
das wegfallende bundestagsbüro und das
wegfallende geld für die mitarbeiter das
wird gerhard schröder wegstecken könnte
man annehmen dass dürften peanuts sein
theo guten abend nach berlin aber
mögliche sanktionen die auch dann
möglicherweise ja sein vermögen
betreffen könnten ist es das was ihn
jetzt zu dem schritt bewogen haben
könnte
also das halte ich jedenfalls für die
schlüssigste erklärung denn keine der
anderen maßnahmen hat es ja geschafft
ihn zu diesem schritt zu bewegen kein
parteiordnungsverfahren keine jahr
flehentlichen anrufer aus der spd-spitze
keine gesellschaftliche ächtung keinen
verlust der ehrenbürgerwürde in hannover
keine aberkennung der privilegien als
altkanzler nichts hat den mann der
früher einmal er ein feines gespür für
politische stimmung hat überhaupt noch
erreicht es liegt also nahe dass die
androhung von massiven vermögensverlust
bei ihm diesen schritt ausgelöst haben
könnte denn sollte die eu resolution
realität werden dann würde sein in
europa vorhandenes vermögen eingefroren
inklusive aller weiteren einkünfte dann
bliebe ihm nur noch geld für das
nötigste und alle finanziellen
bewegungen würden zudem überwacht von
der bundesbank überraschend bleibt sein
mandat hat sich dennoch denn der
aktuelle bundeskanzler hat ja gestern
erklärt er halte einen solchen
sanktionen schritt aktuell gar nicht für
erforderlich und es braucht ja in europa
einstimmigkeit dafür ist denn wirklich
anzunehmen dass mit dem schritte heute
dann die kritik an schröder aus der welt
ist nein ich glaube nicht denn die
indizien sprechen ja weiter gegen
gerhard schröder und gegen einen echten
meinungswandel er verlässt den einen
vorstandsposten aber seinen platz im
gesellschafterausschuss bei der nord
stream ag wurde heute ja überhaupt nicht
erwähnt und auch kein wort zur
halbstaatlichen gazprom denn dort ist er
ja für den aufsichtsrat nominiert die
hauptversammlung ist dann für ende juni
geplant also bei einer echten
haltungsänderung hätte er heute doch
alles abräumen können oder sogar müssen
da gilt mittlerweile wird zu spät kommt
den bestraft dann auch das
geschichtsbuch theo koll zdf berlin
vielen dank
und die aktuelle situation in der
ukraine jetzt mit johanna und christian
blicken wir auf die lage rund um das
seit wochen belagerte als auch stahlwerk
in mario pohl hat russland haben sich
nun auch die letzten verbliebenen
ukrainischen kämpfer ergeben das gebiet
sei damit vollständig unter russischer
kontrolle teilte das
verteidigungsministerium in moskau mit
insgesamt seien seit dem 16 mai mehr als
2400 ukrainische soldaten in russische
gefangenschaft gekommen eine bestätigung
von ukrainischer seite gibt es dafür
nicht
deutschland will unabhängig von
russischem gas werden und dabei soll
katar helfen deshalb hat die
bundesregierung heute eine
energiepartnerschaft mit dem emirat
beschlossen
bundeswirtschaftsminister harbeck und
der energieminister von katar
unterzeichneten dazu eine
absichtserklärung
der emir von katar scheich tamim als
ernie sprach von einer ausweitung der
flüsse gaslieferungen ab 2006 der
scheich ist gerade zum staatsbesuch in
deutschland und traf auch
bundespräsident steinmeier und
bundeskanzler chance
trotz zahlreicher bedenken hat der
bundestag die mandate für den bundeswehr
einsatz in mali verlängert und zwar bis
mai 2023
demnach sollen bis zu 1400 soldatinnen
und soldaten für den stabilisierungs
einsatz der vereinten nationen kurz -
mal im einsatz sein allerdings sieht der
beschluss auch eine rückzugs klausel vor
wenn der schutz und die versorgung der
kräfte nicht gewährleistet werden kann
die beteiligung an der eu
ausbildungsmission soll dagegen
weitgehend eingestellt und ins
nachbarland niger verlegt werden
lange war unklar wann genau die ukraine
mit einer lieferung von schweren waffen
aus deutschland rechnen kann nun ist
klar bis mitte juli sollen 15 gebhardt
panzer bereitgestellt werden neben den
flug ab der panzern wird auch
ausreichend munition zur verfügung
gestellt zudem sollen die ukrainischen
soldaten im vorfeld von der bundeswehr
geschult werden
in deutschland wurde ein erster fall des
affen pockenvirus nachgewiesen betroffen
sei ein 26-jähriger teilte das
bayerische gesundheitsministerium mit
seit anfang mai sind in europa und
nordamerika mehrere fälle von affen
pocken entdeckt worden zu den symptomen
gehören unter anderem fieber und
hautausschlag die meisten verläufe sind
mild nur sehr selten ist die erkrankung
tödlich übertragen wird das virus
bisherigen erkenntnissen zufolge vor
allem durch direkten kontakt zb mit
körperflüssigkeiten gesundheitsminister
lauterbach sprach von einem virus das
nicht so leicht übertragbar sei
er bete dass bald frieden herrscht
schreibt der außenminister des vatikan
heute ins ehrenbuch der kathedrale zu
kiew was er ansonsten genau dort tut
bleibt im ungefähren vatikanische
diplomatie ist immer schon
geheimdiplomatie und hatte auch deshalb
immer wieder erfolg den man aber eben
häufig erst mit verzögerung registriert
ob das auch für den krieg in der ukraine
gilt es wachsen die zweifel der
vatikanische außenbeauftragte ist also
in der ukraine sein chef bislang nicht
und überhaupt fällt der papst gerade mit
äußerungen auf die bei vielen
beobachtern auf unverständnis stoßen der
vatikan hat einiges zu erklären andreas
postel aus rom
am morgen in butscher papst franziskus
hat seinen außenminister aus rom nach
kiew entsandt erzbischof paul richards
gallagher soll vor ort irritationen
ausräumen vatikan diplomatie in einem
minenfeld
rückblende anfang april im päpstlichen
fliege auf der malta reise während alle
welt eine reise in die entgegengesetzte
richtung nach kiew erwartet und papst
franziskus sagt und journalisten ja
diese option liege auf dem tisch er sei
bereit alles zu tun um sich für den
frieden einzusetzen und hoffe auf ein
treffen mit dem russisch-orthodoxen
patriarchen kirill schon da zeichnete
sich ab dass wird kompliziert
sieben wochen des krieges später steht
aber eben nicht franziskus sondern
erzbischof gelder an den gräbern von
butscher gegenüber dem ukrainischen
außenminister wird er dann deutlich
mein besuch demonstriert die nähe des
heiligen stuhls und vom papst franziskus
mit dem ukrainischen volk vor dem
hintergrund der russischen aggression
gegen die ukraine
der vatikan steckt in einem dilemma
einerseits hat pabst franziskus seit
ausbruch des krieges bei jedem anlass
das töten das leid und die zerstörung
auf das schärfste verurteilt
andererseits hat er bis heute vermieden
putin als den aggressor anzuprangern
dahinter steckt der grundsatz des
heiligen stuhls die eigene
vermittlungsrolle nicht durch einseitige
parteinahme zu torpedieren
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt sei mit einer
reise nach kiew keine friedenslösung
erreichbar
in diesem sinne will jetzt franziskus
nicht einfach nach schief gehen
damit es nicht so aussieht nach einem
politischen marketing sondern er findet
dass putin der punkt ist wo eine
friedenslösung
gesucht werden muss für irritationen
sorgte dieses interview im corriere
della sera da papst franziskus darin
putin wieder nicht benennt dafür aber
die nato kritisierte als putin verstehe
und russland freund wird er daraufhin
beschimpft zudem wächst die sorge dass
es bei zu viel diplomatischer
zurückhaltung wie unter papst pius dem
zwölften gegenüber den nazis am ende zu
spät sein könnte
besonders aber das zunehmend belastete
verhältnis zwischen vatikan und russisch
orthodoxer kirche erschwert eine
herausragende vermittlerrolle in dem
konflikt nach der enttäuschenden video
schalte mit kyrill bezeichnet papst
franziskus den patriarchen aus moskau
als putins messdiener
früher wurden die chancen durch
exkommunikation wirksam heute passiert
das durch interviews über internet mit
einer pressemitteilung das sind dann
kulturelle spaltungen zwischen zwei
welten eine
verzwickte lage aus der kein leichter
ausweg sichtbar ist um das leid der
menschen in der ukraine zu lindern dafür
hat der außen gesandte des papstes
humanitäre hilfe im gepäck und das
versprechen aus rom weiterhin alles zu
tun um an einer friedenslösung zu
arbeiten
die aktuell starke inflation macht sich
mehr und mehr im portemonnaie bemerkbar
ein problem das auch thema beim treffen
der
g7-finanzminister war laut
bundesfinanzminister lindner wollen die
führenden industrienationen nun mit
konsequenten maßnahmen dagegen vorgehen
weil die halle in frankfurt sind sich
die g7 denn einig wie das genau aussehen
soll im grunde ja sie sind sich einig
das hat ja auch finanzminister lindner
betont nur beim timing sind sie sich
nicht ganz so einig die amerikaner sind
wesentlich hemdsärmeliger als die
europäer haben schon zweimal die zinsen
erhöht in europa rechnet man mit einer
ersten zinsanhebung im juli aber unterm
strich ist allen klar die hohe inflation
ist ein großes problem für haushalte und
unternehmen rund um den globus sind die
notenbanken in zugzwang die
inflationsraten auf höchstständen in den
usa im april bei 8,3 prozent 7,4 in der
eurozone und 7,8 prozent in deutschland
die sorge ist dass sich der hohe
preisauftrieb verfestigen könnte zumal
unternehmensumfragen ergeben dass die
meisten firmen in deutschland weitere
preiserhöhungen planen jetzt macht china
gerade das gegenteil dort wurde nun wo
nun die zinsen gesenkt wie wird das
begründet in erster linie mit der harten
corona politik erklärt man sich dass
unter der die menschen sehr leiden aber
eben auch die konjunktur die lok downs
drohen die wirtschaft abzuwürgen und
peking steuert jetzt mit einer
zinssenkung gegen in der hoffnung dass
das investitionen ankurbelt und die
konjunktur wieder in schwung bringt ob
das reicht das bezweifeln viele je
länger die krise dort dauert desto
schwerer treffen die folgen auch
deutschland vielen dank valerie nach
frankfurt
und noch zwei meldungen vom sport
borussia dortmund gab überraschend die
trennung von trainer marco rose bekannt
und das noch nach nur einer saison
favorit für die nachfolge ist die den pc
und auch bei borussia mönchengladbach
steht offenbar ein wechsel an der spitze
an und eine rückkehr lucien favre soll
zum zweiten mal trainer der gladbacher
werden
mit mehr als zwei jahren verzögerung ist
eine raumkapsel des us luftfahrtkonzern
boeing zu einem testflug in richtung iss
aufgebrochen der starliner startete vom
weltraumbahnhof cape canaveral in der
vergangenheit hatten pannen den start
verhindert aktuell ist nur eine dame
gruppe an bord zeitnah sein aber auch
bemannte flüge geplant der starliner
soll die iss heute nacht erreichen
so wünschen wir der damp-gruppe alles
gute das war unsere welt an diesem
freitag und im heute-journal update
nachher ein film über einen schwedisch
iranischen wissenschaftler der morgen
von iran hingerichtet werden soll ja das
ist ein verzweifelter kampf gegen die
zeit nachher im heute-journal update um
00 15 so das politbarometer ist ja immer
dann besonders spannend wenn die sich
dort ordentlich was tut so wie heute die
ganz aktuelle ausgabe mit matthias
fornoff jetzt für sie ein angenehm
guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer
welcher wind weht aus kiel und
düsseldorf nach berlin die beiden
landtagswahlen haben bewegungen in die
bundesweite wählerstimmung gebracht das
zutrauen in die union ist mit den
erfolgen der cdu in schleswig-holstein
und nordrhein-westfalen gestiegen auch
die grünen legen stark zu und kommen auf
ihr bestes ergebnis seit einem jahr die
spd dagegen rutscht auf ihren
schwächsten wert seit september wenn am
nächsten sonntag bundestagswahl wäre
käme die spd auf 22 prozent minus 3 die
cdu/csu liegt jetzt vor der spd mit 26
prozent plus drei grüne 24 prozent +3
fdp 7 -2 afd 10 minus 1 die linke 4
prozent unverändert
nach diesen zahlen ist für eine
regierungsmehrheit im bundestag ein
dreierbündnis mehr erforderlich reichen
würde es für schwarz grün und knapp auch
für rot grün was bedeutet diese
kräfteverschiebung für die amtierende
ampelkoalition
die regierung aus spd grünen und fdp
wird bis zur nächsten wahl
2025 halten meinen drei viertel der
befragten vor allem die anhänger der
regierungsparteien sehen das mit großer
mehrheit so etwas weniger überzeugt sind
die anhänger der opposition bei
der bewertung der einzelnen
regierungsparteien bekommen die grünen
mit abstand die besten noten
auch bei den politikern erreichen die
grünen robert habeck und annalena
baerbock neue persönliche bestwerte
unsere top ten der nach meinung der
befragten wichtigsten politikerinnen und
politiker nach sympathie und leistung
auf der skala von plus fünf bis minus
fünf
schlusslicht ist jetzt christine
lambrecht minus 0,8 deutlich
verschlechtert davor sahra wagenknecht
minus 0,5 auf rang 8 markus söder 0,1
vor ihm friedrich merz 0,2 alle
verbessert das ja lindner 0,5 schlechter
karl lauterbach 0,6 vor ihm cem özdemir
1,0 auf rang 3 olaf scholz 1,1 alle drei
unverändert annalena baerbock 1,9 sehr
viel besser an der spitze weiter robert
habeck 2,1 verbessert
zum erfolg der grünen trägt auch ihr
krisenmanagement im ukraine krieg bei
bundeskanzler scholz hat seine linie
zuletzt häufiger erklärt wird aber
weiterhin schlechter bewertet als die
koalitionspartner
jeder zweite findet kanzler stolz macht
seine arbeit in der ukraine krise gut
41 prozent sehen das nicht so bei
vizekanzler robert habeck sind 67
prozent zufrieden und 18 prozent nicht
am besten schneidet außenministerin
annalena baerbock ab mit 74 prozent
zustimmung jeder fünfte meint aber sie
macht ihre arbeit schlecht
dass deutschland der ukraine schwere
waffen wie panzer liefert findet eine
mehrheit richtig hier gibt es aber
deutliche regionale unterschiede im
westen befürworten das 62 im osten nur
41 prozent
wegen des angriffs russlands auf die
ukraine haben finnland und schweden
jetzt die aufnahme in die nato beantragt
was bei uns auf große zustimmung trifft
81 prozent der deutschen finden einen
beitritt von finnland und schweden zum
westlichen verteidigungsbündnis gut nur
13 prozent sind dagegen
das vertrauen in russische
energielieferungen ist seit kriegsbeginn
stark gesunken die mehrheit der
befragten glaubt nicht dass russland
weiter zuverlässig erdgas liefert ende
januar waren die deutschen noch
mehrheitlich davon überzeugt umso
wichtiger werden die energiewende und
die unabhängigkeit von russischen
rohstoffen der ausbau erneuerbarer
energien geht nur jedem zehnten
deutschen zu schnell
64 prozent sagen das geht so langsam und
ein viertel findet das tempo beim ausbau
genau richtig
energiewende ja aber bitte nicht im
eigenen vorgarten denn wenn es um den
bau von mehr windrädern geht meint eine
mehrheit der deutschen die
vorgeschriebenen mindestabstände zu
wohnhäusern sollten besser nicht
verringert werden
blicken wir noch auf ein anderes thema
corona hier herrscht zurzeit das prinzip
hoffnung
nur noch 30 prozent der deutschen halten
ihre eigene gesundheit durch das virus
für gefährdet so niedrig war der wert
noch nie seit beginn der pandemie
63 prozent sehen für sich persönlich
derzeit keine gefahr
entwarnung ist nach ansicht von
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach noch
nicht angesagt aber der wunsch nach
einer corona verschnaufpause bis groß
das war unser bericht über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
in der zdf- heute- app und auf zdf
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
umfragen der forschungsgruppe wahlen
zustande kommen informationen zur
methodik und zu den qualitätsstandards
finden sie unter politbarometer punkt
zdf.de
vielen dank für ihr interesse das
nächste politbarometer gibt es dann am
17 juni und nach dem wetter geht's hier
weiter mit der heute-show ihnen noch
einen schönen abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
zugute und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter die teilweise extremen unwetter
heute hatten mit einem tief zu tun was
sich erst einmal bilden musste und zwar
ganz weit im westen über frankreich kam
es zusammen ja und schob sich dann
weiter richtung deutschland und
währenddessen hat es sich noch weiter
entwickelt diese roten flecken das sind
teilweise gewitter und teilweise gab es
super zellen und eben auch den tornado
im westen deutschlands ja und es kann
sein dass es noch weitere tornados
gegeben hat das wird sich dann im
nachhinein klären es geht aber immer
noch zur sache im süden deutschlands vor
allem haben wir es hier noch mit
schauern und gewittern zu tun die sind
noch im unwetter bereich mindestens noch
in den nächsten stunden und danach wird
das allmählich nachlassen aber im süden
deutschlands wird es durchaus weiter
regnen der regen hier verbunden
teilweise mit schauern teils gewittrig
wird abziehen und ganz im norden das
auch noch etwas regen dabei aber das
ganze wird allmählich ruhiger bei
temperaturen von zehn grad richtung
nordsee und 17 grad im osten
deutschlands und genauso 17 grad im
südwesten
dort also relativ mild
ja und morgen dann schauer und auch
gewitter nach nordosten hin und letzte
schauer im süden sonst lockert es auf
vor allem im südwesten
in der mitte sind die wolken durchaus
dichte aber es beruhigt sich zum teil
und die temperaturen bei 16 bis 18 grad
im norden und bis 27 grad im südwesten
deutschlands am sonntag gibt es durchaus
im süden gewitter ansonsten aber
aufgelockert teils mit sonnenschein 17
bis 26 grad montag die nächsten gewitter
teilweise im unwetter bereich bei 20 bis
27 grad und auch dienstag ist ziemlich
durchwachsen kommen sie gut durch die
gewitter und ein schöner abend